well war games involving the u.s ukraine
and 30 other nations are wrapping up in
the black sea operation seabreeze has
been held despite strong objections from
russia
the largest maneuvers in decades have
been taking place around the waters of
crimea
which russia annexed from ukraine in
2014.
kiev wants to join the nato alliance and
will host more exercises with the us
poland and lithuania later this month
and i'm now joined by alexander cara
foreign policy and security analyst
from the center for defense strategies
based in kiev
thank you so much for joining us on the
show first i want to just
ask you what is the point of these
drills
first of all it's a bilateral drills
where ukraine invites other
nato partner partner countries and other
uh western oriented countries uh
the uh the key signal of those
exercises i mean this 2021 is to show
the strong support of ukraine
in face of ongoing russian aggression in
dambass
and illegal nexation of crimea and then
creeping annexation of other territories
like the territorial waters around
crimea and sea of azov
since 2018 russia imposed blockade of
the uh on ukrainian ports of azo
and that's why it's so important to show
that ukraine is not alone
in in its conflict with russia uh
secondly
uh as we uh proclaim that the nato
membership is our strategic goal
and majority of ukrainians support such
a move
uh it's a really important thing to get
more interoperability with nato
countries and to be more ready to get
the membership
action plan thanks to the recent
decision of the
nato summit uh ukraine will get this
opportunity to become a member while the
membership action plan
and finally uh it's a good opportunity
to strengthen regional cooperation and
to show
the region powers and powers beyond the
region
the threats that russia pose not just to
ukraine not just to the region
but to the european continent as a whole
a heavy militarization of crimea
including the nuclear component
is this direct threat to europe uh the
equilibrium missiles
are capable of reaching each and every
capital in europe
and these missiles are incapable of
carrying the nuclear warheads so
uh the militaries of different nations
who are taking part in this
uh exercise can see what techniques are
russia is developing and is trying to
mirror
in other uh areas like black baltic sea
like in the arctic or in the far east
now it's understandable that ukraine
wants to see a strong
show of support given its nato ambitions
but are these drills the best way to do
it
well i think in face of aggression uh
the best way to show the strengths of
the society and we've seen it
since 2014 ukrainian civil society
showed that there is no willingness to
be
under the russian rule or to be in the
sphere of influence of russia
secondly consequent uh presidents not
just
so-called nationalistic poroshenko but
the more pro-russian
uh in his views uh zielinski is showing
that we
uh we choose our paths to towards the
west and certainly our
military is the best defense against uh
ongoing uh
aggression uh while we are not under the
uh article five of the washington treaty
and
we are visibly with russia so
strengthening ourselves is the best way
how to show that there will be a higher
cost of
russia if they decide to move for and to
intervene in ukraine more than in crimea
and ambassador
now at the end of the day though these
sailors are going to be going home and
russia will continue to assert control
over the crimean peninsula so do these
drills actually
make a difference besides being a show
of force
uh certainly uh it's as i said that the
ukrainian military
are better in better shape and because
of this cooperation and
established ties they will be more
capable of doing things
then uh the recent going program with
the united states united kingdom and
turkey
how to rebuild a ukrainian navy as we
lost
capacities uh during the annexation of
crimea
and that's why uh as far uh as the
maritime security concerned ukraine is
most vulnerable from the
southern from the sea direction that's
why
these exercises along with the
building capacity of ukraine to defend
itself on the sea
is a really good move and i i would like
to say that uh
the rotational presence of the uh known
black sea nato countries
is really important and what we've seen
just a couple of
weeks ago with the hms defender who
uh touched a territorial waters of
ukraine uh around crimea that caused
a nervous reaction in kremlin it's a
right move to do
because freedom of negation is something
really important not just for ukraine
but the whole world and that's why uh
the whole world should support ukraine
showing that russia cannot set its rules
in the black sea area
all right alexander cara from the center
for defense strategies joining us from
kiev thank you so much
thank you